SPEAKER: Instead of developers
accessing your backend services
directly, they can be exposed
through API Proxies on Apigee,
which are HTTP endpoints.
The proxy manages
any code changes
on the backend and avoids
disruptions for developers
until a new version of
the API is warranted.
An API Proxy enables you
to apply security features
and force access
limits and quotas,
provide caching,
create transformations,
and handle errors.
It also lets you
perform monitoring
and create analytic reports.
You usually group multiple API
Proxies into an API product
and offer that as
a service plan.
For example, you may want
to provide an API product
for free up to a certain request
limit per day for developers
to try out your API.
But we'll cover that
in another episode.
You will have some flexibility
when creating your API Proxy.
And so to get started,
in this episode,
I will walk you through how
to build your first API Proxy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before getting
started, you will need
to have configured
access to your API
Proxy either externally
or internally.
I have linked instructions in
this video called Accessing API
Proxies.
Next, visit the Apigee
console at apigee.google.com.
Then Develop API Proxies.
Then select Create New.
This will prompt
the proxy wizard,
and you will choose
Reverse Proxy.
Next, enter the following
values for the proxy name,
proxy based path, description,
and the target existing API.
Then click Next, and Apigee
will create your proxy.
Next, choose to visit
the API Proxy list
so that we can deploy
our proxy by returning
to Develop API Proxies again.
Next, ensure you are on
your eval environment
by looking at the top.
Otherwise, use the dropdown
to change environments.
Click on My Proxy.
Then notice that under
Deployments, the revision
column shows Not Deployed.
Next, from the
revision dropdown,
choose one as this is the first
version and then click Deploy.
After a few seconds pass, you
can see from the status bar
when your proxy
is fully deployed.
Now, you can test the API
Proxy by using the command line
terminal.
As a friendly reminder, if
you haven't configured access
to your proxies either
internally or externally,
I have linked instructions
on how to do that.
Note that in my
case, the external IP
provided by an
external load balancer
is registered with a
DNS-registered hostname.
Next, if the call succeeds,
you will see the Hello Guest
as the output.
Now, let's try changing the
target endpoint to output XML.
So let's return to
Develop, API proxies again,
select your desired proxy.
Then on the top far
right, click Develop,
which will take you to
the API Proxy editor,
which lets you see the
structure of your API Proxy
and configure its flow.
In the Navigator pane, select
Target Endpoints PreFlow
On the Code pane, you can
spot your target URL endpoint.
Next, append forward slash
XML to the existing URL
so that it looks like this.
Next, click Save.
You'll be asked to save
it as a new revision
since you already
deployed revision one,
and that can't be changed.
Then deploy it to
the new revision
by selecting the button Deploy
To Eval and choose Deploy To.
Test your changes
by sending a request
to your proxy via
command line just
like we did earlier, like this.
And this should return XML.
Now, let's add a policy to
convert that XML into JSON.
We will use an XML to JSON
policy in the proxy response
flow.
This policy converts the payload
of an XML message to JSON.
It also changes the response's
content type header.
To add the XML to JSON
policy to your proxy, let's
return to API Proxies Develop.
Select your desired proxy.
Then on the top far
right, click Develop.
This time, click Proxy,
Endpoints, Default, PreFlow.
To add a policy to your proxy,
click the Plus Step button
in the response PreFlow, the
bottom half of the flow editor.
Apigee displays a
categorized list
of policies in
the Add dialog box
that you can add to your flow.
Scroll down and select
the XML to JSON policy.
Leave the default
names and click Add.
Apigee attaches the new policy
to the PreFlow of the response,
which does three things.
One, it adds the new policy
under Policies in the Navigator
pane.
Two, it adds the XML to JSON
policy in the flow pane.
And three, it displays the
policy's configuration XML
in the code pane.
We'll just use the default
configuration that's suggested.
But this can be customized.
Next, click Save.
And test it out with the
following co-command.
Congrats.
You've successfully
added the XML
to JSON policy to
your new proxy.
As a next step, I have linked,
in this video's description,
more information on how to
add additional functionality
to your API proxies
if you're interested.
In the next episode,
I will walk you
through how to apply
Apigee security
policies to your proxy.
So stay tuned.
And friends, if you found
this episode helpful,
you can click Like or
Subscribe to the channel.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]